I mean does it feel like an
embarrassment of riches cuz obviously
you are part of a hit TV show Outlander
and then to be part of a film that's
being recognized in this way not just by
producers guild but also the Academy I
mean what does that feel like
definitely pinch me moment yeah this
does not happen very often so it's very
exciting it's very cool I mean I loved
being part of the film it was so much
fun to film and it was so much fun to
work with Kristian and with Jim and with
Matt so yeah this is these are good days
cool these are good days I loved the
movie and it's just also this movie
where it's this big great movie to see
in a theatre with these big stars did
you I don't know if you'd worked with
Kristian or Matt before but did you have
favorite movies of theirs and did you
have to discuss anything with them I
mean I I think I've seen probably nearly
every film Christmas done I mean he's
just he's such a class act and he's such
a talent and Matt as well I mean I don't
know it's I was very intimidated I think
the first day but they're both the most
normal like just family guys that when
you meet them they just put you at ease
and we all got stuck into the work and
it was really fun you know where we're
trying to ask as many people as we can
tonight
this is one of those nights where you
see the hustle that people have put into
everything was there a time in your
career when you got a no and if so how
did you push past it I know you did
remember one that sticks out to you a
big I mean I spent about four years in
LA getting knows so I don't know I mean
you know those things they you got to
take the lesson right you got to learn
from it and move on and and just when
you get the yes yeah make sure you make
it worthwhile and movie they got the
nose and I will say you got a big yes
with Outlander I can't let you leave
without getting some tea from season
five because obviously you know Claire
is kind of at a crossroads and so I know
a lot of fans out there I think the
question for you is whether or not you
think Bri and Roger should stay in the
past or return to their own time oh I
mean that's a hard one well I think
Claire feels that I think she she wants
them to go back I think she feels that
they would be safer and they would be
happier there but it breaks their heart
to say that Katrine
things they should stay so I don't know
conflicting interests here within myself
it's just like a battle going on in my
own head I don't have to decide though
so it's great the writers get to decide
that it's so wonderful to see you enjoy
your night Thank You Cecil thank you
[Music]